θα υμάζω πάρα πολύ κάποιες γυναίκες και οικογένειες που γνώρισα αυτά τα κοσιδύο χρόνια που
κανένας δεν ξέρει τον αγόνα τους την προσπάθεια τους πολλές φορές μας βέπουν εμάς αλλάπραγματικά
είναι μια με συντροφεύει οι αγκαλιά που μιράζομε με όλες αυτές τις γυναίκες και τις
οικογένεις τους όλα αυτά τα χρόνια και έχω να πω μόνο ένα εντεράστο ευχαριστώ ότι
ότι ξέρετε ότι η αγκαλιά είναι σηματική και για μένα έρχεται και για μένα ω
ια πολύ θετικό συνέίσθημα ότι αυτό που κάνουμε είναι σωστό και να προχωράμε σίγουρα θα
ταν δεκάδες οι φορές που χτύπησα το τηλέφωνο της τελασκυριακήτου που κάποια γυναίκα που περνούσε
τον δικό της ποβλημα με τον καρκίνο πύρχα στιγμές που μόλις χτύπησε το ηλέωνο ι
στέλνα μπήκε στο αυτοκίνητο και έτρε ξε ναύρει αυτή τη γυναίκαα πολλες να ειζώσει το
γουράγιο πάρα πολλές ς πάρα πολλές φορές και προσπαθώ να είναι εκεί και στις βριξέλες
που είμαι έχω υπάρχει μια όματα γυναικών που επικεινωνού μαζί μου και και κουβεντιάζουμε τα
διάφορα θέματα αλλά ναι πάρα πολλές φορές θα πως το υτοκίνητο θα πάω στο σπίτι
θα καθίσω να μιλήσω δεν θέλω πιστεπω ότικα μια γυναίκα και κανένας ασθενείς δεν πρέπει
να εσθάνεται μόνος του να ευνιώθει ότι πάντε υπάρχει αναχαίρι που μπορεί να τον κρατήσει
και σα ν επιτροπος δώσατε μάχες για θέματα του καρκίνου πιστεπε ότι να έχετε αφήσει
της βάσεις για να χτιστεί κάτι καλύτερο γύρω από αυτό το πράγμα που νομάζεται καρκίένα
φύπολαέχουμε το πιο ς